what's going on everybody it's Warren
and one of the biggest questions that
fans have been asking for a very long
time now about Avengers in game is will
Tony Stark die
iron man started the MCU a little over
ten years ago and with Avengers in game
wrapping up the story arc from the first
ten years people are wondering if the
man who started it all will end with it
all and there's some new information
that has come to the surface that leads
us to believe that this may be it for
him quick reminder about my giveaway I'm
giving away five imax tickets so you and
some friends can go see Avengers in game
in IMAX if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain Marvel Studios President Kevin
Feige has made it very clear that we're
about to see some pretty big changes in
the MCU in fact he has talked about
taking away the phases of the MCU all
together after Avengers in game plus it
has been stated that the future of the
MCU is actually a cosmic future with the
upcoming films exploring the cosmic
universe so we'll have more films like
the guardians of the galaxy and Captain
Marvel so with the future of the MCU
changing does Ironman have a place in it
Robert Downey jr. x' contract is up
after Avengers in game and as far as we
know he has chosen to not renew it also
Gwyneth Paltrow who plays Pepper Potts
in the MCU who is currently Tony Stark's
fiancee has come out and openly stated
that she will no longer be appearing in
any more MCU films so it'll be the end
for Pepper Potts which leads people to
believe even more that it will be the
end for Iron Man but recently some more
information has arise in regards to
Avengers in game being Robert Downey jr.
'he's last film and the last film for
Tony Stark
according to we got this covered calm a
source very close to them told them that
Avengers in game will in fact be Robert
Downey jr. 'he's last movie in the MCU
so Avengers in game will be the last
movie for Robert Downey jr. in the MCU
which means no more Iron Man played by
Robert Downey jr. this doesn't
necessarily mean that he's going to die
he could just retire but it would be
weird to not have Iron Man played by
Robert Downey jr. pop up randomly
throughout the MCU in future films
especially since Stark Industries plays
a pretty big part in the MCU and
Captain Marvel is supposed to lead the
New Avengers moving forward and she's
going to work directly with Iron Man in
Avengers in game so it would be odd for
him not to pop up randomly even if it's
just as a mentor and not to mention he
was nowhere to be found in the
spider-man far from home trailer and he
was the one that was looking after Peter
Parker and now all of a sudden it's
happy Hogan and Nick Fury who are
looking after him so again Tony Stark
could retire but there are certainly a
lot of signs that lead us to believe
that he could die in Avengers in game it
would be quite a way to go seeing Tony
Stark's sacrificed himself in a heroic
way to save the rest of the Avengers and
the universe and they could play a big
tribute to him at the end of the movie
but of course this is just speculation
but tell me what you think about the
news that Robert Downey jr. will no
longer appear in any future MCU films do
you think Iron Man will die in Avengers
in game or do you think it will end with
him retiring let me know your thoughts
in the comments down below and again
don't forget to subscribe comment and
like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to marvel and
Avengers in game as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]